we covered woke Snow White no longer
white snow taupe snow beige snow swarthy
snow not well Snow's not swarthy I don't
some kind of sediment or sand that is no
longer
Blanc this young woman just explained be
far more egregious changes to the story
than the casting of this out of place
actress you said you were bringing a
Modern Edge to it on stage what do you
mean by that I just mean that it's no
longer 1937 and we absolutely wrote a
snow white that is not going to be saved
by the prince she's not going to be
saved for The Prince and she's not going
to be dreaming about true love she's
dreaming about becoming the leader she
knows she can be this is the central
feature of the movie is that it's a
movie about love and that she is
reawoken but by love they're taking the
love out of it no it's not about Prince
Charming and love anymore it's about
what a girl boss she is because that's
what little girls dream of they dream of
being a girl boss